العقيد الفلاحي اهلا بك التحقيقات التي
تفتح تبدو امرا روتينيا لكن اسمح لي هنا
بعد كل فشل
اسرائيلي التحقيقات لا تغير شيئا على
المشهد على على الارض ودائما هنالك
السيناريو اليوم الاصعب الذي تحدثنا عنه
امس مباشره عقب الاعلان عن هذه العمليه ما
الاشكال الذي يعاني منه الجيش الاسرائيلي
هنا نعم حقيقه الاشكالات التي يعاني منها
الجيش الصهيوني هي اشكالات كبيره على
المستوى الاستراتيجي على المستوى
العملياتي وعلى المستوى التكتيكي ولكن قبل
هذا دعني اقول بانه اذا ما اردنا ان نرجع
الى فاتوره الخسائر للجيش الصهيوني خلال
الفتره الماضيه نجد بان هناك ايام تجاوزت
هذا العدد اللي هو عدد
24 هناك ايام مصلت الى اكثر من 3 بين قتيل
وجريح لم تكن هذه الضجه الان التي موجوده
في الكيان الصهيوني على المستوى السياسي
وعلى المستوى العسكري ولكن يبدو لي من
خلال المتابعه والمراقبه بان الاعداد
والخسائر هي اكبر من الرقم الذي تم اعلانه
بكثير لذلك احدثت هذه الضجه الكبيره في
المؤسسه العسكريه والمؤسسه السياسيه والا
اذا جئنا الى فاتوره الخسائر نجد بان هناك
ارقام اكبر من هذا بكثير في الايام
الماضيه خصوصا عندما كانت المعارك تحتدم
في نعم وليس لدينا ارقام عن الجرحه في هذه
العمليه ايضا
نعم اكيد يعني اكيد يعني اذا ما جينا الى
العمليات في القاطع الشمالي كانت هناك
خسائر في اليوم تتجاوز ال 30 بين قتيل
وجريح اما هذه العمليه لم يتكلموا الا عن
24 شخص يعني ولم يتكلموا عن اعداد الجرحى
علما بان الارقام انا اعتقد واجزم بانها
تكاد تفوق هذه الاعداد بالكثير من الارقام
لذلك انا اعتقد بان الجيش الصهيوني يعاني
من اشكالات حقيقيه في هذه المساله اولا
بانه المقاومه نجحت في الوصول والتسلل الى
مناطق هي في مناطق يمكن ان نقول انها تحكم
السيطره عليها بشكل كامل هذا اولا المساله
الاخرى هناك خلل كبير جدا عندما تكون مثل
هذه البنايات ومعرضه للتخريب يجب ان لا
تكون هذه الاعداد الكبيره في هذه المناطق
ولكن يبدو بان هذه المنطقه كانت مؤخره
يعني هو التخريب المؤجل الى فتره قادمه او
وقت اخر فلذلك تواجدت هذه الاعداد الكبيره
ضمن هذين البنائين وبالتالي عمليه اطلاق
الصاروخ من قبل فصائل المقاومه ادى الى
تفجير هذه المتفجرات التي وضعت في هذه الب
البنايات الامر الذي ادى الى وقوع هذه
الاعداد الكبيره اما اذا جئنا على الجيش
فنجد بان الجيش هناك اشكاليه حقيقيه في
مساله القتال في المناطق المبنيه يعني هذه
التعبئه تحتاج الى قطاعات خاصه والى
امكانيات خاصه في العمل يضاف الى ذلك بانك
يجب ان تاخذ دائما اسوا الاحتمالات التي
يمكن ان تحدث بما فيها بانه دائما تكون
الاعداد الجنود قليله جدا وتكون المسافات
متباعده ما بين شخص واخر يضاف الى ذلك
بانه المناطق عندما تريد التفخيخ لا يتم
تفخيخ البنايه كلها من من الاسفل الى
الاعلى وانما يتم تفخيخها من الاسفل في
مكانات محدده بحيث تؤدي الى انهيار هذه
البنايات وبالتالي عندما تتساءل عن
الاعداد الحقيقيه لهذا التفجير لا تجد
اعداد حقيقيه ولكن تجد اعداد بسيطه تم
اعلانها من قبل جيش الاحتلال في هذه
العمليه اشكرك من اسطنبول العقيد حاتم
كريم الفلاحي الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي